we are still in a crisis that has never
once been treated as a crisis we do have
lots of brilliant solutions we have
unprecedented wealth and financial
assets we have a lot of goodwill and
countless of people ready to do
everything they can to help what we do
not have is awareness leadership and
above all time no policy plan or deal
will be nearly enough as long as you
just continue to ignore the co2 budget
which applies for today we don't just
need goals for 2030 or 2050 we above all
need them for 2020 and for every
following year to come we need to start
cutting our emissions drastically at the
source now your distant targets will
mean nothing if high emissions continue
like today's business as usual the EU
must lead the way you have the moral
obligation to do so and you have a
unique economical and political
opportunity to become a real climate
leader you yourselves declared that we
are in a climate and environment
emergency you said this was an
existential threat now you must prove
that you mean it
[Applause]